the highly anticipated expansion pack
for destiny the taken king is finally
out Eric Tay and Mike McCarty you boys
put in some work you stayed here after
TGS 2am played taking king on a live
stream for hours and hours and hours i
came back in this morning you were still
playing crazy person and but what I want
to know about first of all is that I
viewers of the lobby fans at lobby out
there I want to know you guys had a chat
last week I believe you said the first
one to the hacks love before he was at
PAX first one the 40 was gonna get a
steak dinner purchased by the other I
see some body language here Eric how did
you get on I lost okay but I think at
the end of the day yes he did be me i
will say that but i think at the end of
the day we can both say that it's like
kind of like not what we expected
because i think i think in our minds we
both knew that it would or we both felt
like it would come down to like this
race of like ok he's here I'm here like
if I do this or like if I do this faster
I'm gonna win you'll figure out the
fastest way to 40 or sure yeah and like
it just wasn't that at all literally how
did you get to 40 first go ahead we both
saved up a bunch of bounties a sick like
fulfilled all 16 slots before the
expansion launched so we could turn them
in right away and get the experience
[ __ ] cheese I know a lot of people
did that just to you know think it's the
higher level just to start playing
higher level stuff and have access to
better gear but as it turns out it was
going a lot faster than we thought but I
also had this cloak equipped that he had
but he didn't have it equipped because
he wasn't he didn't know I gave you ten
percent experience and I knew what that
process oh yeah so I started like
popping the bounties and we both felt
their controller vibrating so we backed
out and saw we're level 38 oh where he
was 38 I'm like oh my god I gotta hurry
and I went to turn my bounties I turned
in like all 16 and I backed out said
level 40 and he was like he was like the
last one the last one was a year one
bounty so you couldn't just turn it in
from the screen you actually had to go
to the person rice so I kind of set out
loud like oh [ __ ] I'm out of bounties
and he's like oh no and then I like oh
wait I have one more I go turn then and
I turned out hit 40 while he was kind
a bike Oh calming down I think so like a
matter of seconds yeah a matter of
inches yeah I'm Grable do so that kind
of do you feel like you missed that at
all I mean I don't know it just leveling
I think no because I like to be honest
we had this discussion on the stream
it's like the 40 number was kind of just
like one number for you to get to that
you would just like kind of you would
technically just progress through
through the story hmm but it's not
really the number that matters yeah like
so that's another day let's talk about
what matters then so taking King first
thing I want to know about is one of my
sort of gripes that I have with destiny
as I know I never felt like there isn't
much in terms of like what I like about
games gaming content story missions
stuff that's like unique I always felt
there's a lot of copy and paste destiny
so from what I'm hearing around the
office taken King he's got some really
fascinating story and mission stuff
going on so Eric first of all what ever
think about um so first of all just
structurally how things are like how
they went about it this time is like way
better than what they've done like
previously and I was saying this last
night too they kind of took like a
blizzard model approach with like they
did it with starcraft recently what they
would do is you kind of get like this
lead up to the mission you either have
some type of cinematic or your you know
you have your conversation with your
quest quartermaster quest giver and then
you kind of go along collect ten of
these go do is kill not necessarily like
that anymore but uh you know and then
after your mission you would get a
little bit more story flavor on what you
just did or like what what your next
steps were where some of the like so it
kind of weaves the story better whereas
in the past it was like you kind of got
the mission you did it you kind of heard
from dinkle and then you just kind of
like okay here's the next one so that
just made them feel more special to sort
of flesh them out in terms of like
narrative and cutscenes yeah it just
feels smoother I think and I think even
for me that I don't care that much about
the story personally like what I can
tell what they're doing and and just
seeing the little bits of cinematics
just here and there like I mean granted
it's taking them a year to get here but
like just those little nuggets is like a
big deal i think i've seen quotes of
like the first
30 minutes of taking king as a story is
like killed destiny year one yeah like
that's how good it so how much of that
is there Mike so the main thing that I
like is the characterization I mean
they're telling a story it's a very
small scale story in terms of for
anybody who's actually gone to
bungie.net which I have not done often
but I was so interested in the lore
behind destiny because there's so many
hints at this awesome story but it
wasn't a game there really is a huge
amount of law just so many different you
know like wars in the past that affected
like what happened and the traveler came
okay so how they transitioned out to
actually being in the game there through
the storm not the overarching lore as
much I mean with Oryx being the villain
of the taking heat the taken king and
also a hive King it's kind of taking
themselves are kind of this weird force
that keeps absorbing all the other
factions probably see it soon they
become this new faction that's kind of
just these Spectre looking things that
have new abilities in addition to the
old ones but yeah the characterization
on Nathan Fillion voices Kade the hunter
Vanguard leader and he's kind of the
sarcastic one of the group and he kind
of takes things into his own hands and
just goes off and you know that without
spoiling anything he's just he kind of
you know paves his own route with what
he wants to do and term its come how is
the story like is it is there a lot of
it is there a lot of missions does it
feel like it like in terms of hours have
you completed it yet yo ya the story
does what took us three hours okay for
ya instant replay ability no well so
don't once you beat the taken king which
is like half a story you continue with
table that's the story but you continue
with the taking Wars which those have
more context surrounding them as far as
fighting the taken army kind of after
that it's like n game's single-player
cooperative story content almost it's
separate from strikes and PvP and
everything and reads of the raid
obviously but it's like story-driven
missions you could do single player
co-op I did a few single player but a
and I did a few this morning and yeah
there's there's this good context
surrounding them which i think was lost
on previous destiny missions so you kind
of have a general understanding of why
you're doing what you're doing which is
always nice to me i I'm like Tay I
didn't go into destiny for the story but
it's also it gives you the gas or you
have a sense of impetus when you're
doing something
if you know why you're doing it how its
serving the overall storyline cool so at
side of that I guess the thought core
like sort of three hours of like fleshy
music content what else we looking at
here I know there's a bunch of new
subclasses there's a new area as well
what like checkbox this stuff what are
we looking at and taking uh well we've
yet to see the raid which is like the
big deal of course um it's it's always
been a pretty big deal and you know not
having one in house of wolves and then
now finally having like probably a
proper one well I haven't seen it yet
but I was going to assume because they
basically took one off right the new
area is great I think we're we're seeing
some of it here the dread-nots it's a
ship that's right outside the rings of
Saturn I believe we're right inside them
floating um and the cool thing about it
is there's so much stuff you're like
trying to find like little nooks and
crannies some of them are quests related
like go find these calcium fragments and
you just you just look around the
environment and you're like maybe
there's one there and I'm literally
jumping everywhere trying to find this
stuff and that's the kind of cool names
right there's even there was even this
other spot that I haven't confirmed this
but I've heard I've heard some stuff is
that some of these quests require you to
do things like you have to dance to
trigger the event or like there's like a
sparrow event or something it's like
some dark souls blob or yeah exactly so
then I started doing blood-borne things
I started triggering my my point I tried
to way but you know like and that wasn't
really in destiny before I mean like
sure there were some secrets but it
feels like the dread-nots like the area
itself there's just so many secrets
there's all these chests it's like you
need a key of something to open this
like where the hell do I get this key
I'm like there's a numerous amounts of
things and we haven't even tried the
court of work so there's just a bunch of
stuff and a bunch of new stuff and i
think i was telling Mike this I I mean I
know why there's so many dlcs in between
something like this like a meaty a
really meaty DLC this this to me is more
like a WoW expansion yeah we're like you
you've been playing the main game you
playing the main game and then here's
your game changer like right like here's
something new you're kind of starting
all over again and that's kind of why I
like I was going all-in I was just like
I kept playing because I was like
just like leveling again re getting my
gear and like that the grind is back and
unfortunately I will say the grind is
like pretty grindy though so like so
someone that's casuals probably not
gonna make the raid Friday but like you
know world first people will go for it
that's what they want right and then
like people slowly get into it so let's
let's talk about the final sort of the
piece of the puzzle then obviously there
is a review in progress up on gamespot
com ran it right now and we sort of get
into a lot of what we talked about
already and why is the full review not
up as of yet them sure so I played about
15 hours of taking King a couple weeks
ago and I got to play through the story
the endgame single-player content at
least most of it pvp maps which have
been out for a week now actually as of
today people have to pay for those now
ones but I played the strikes and
everything but I didn't play nearly
enough to see how the quest system will
figure into and just like the gaining
better loot and you know the grind this
taste said would how it will continue
after that 15 hour mark because 15 hours
is not that much in destiny and I also I
wanted to go back and play with a lower
level character so this is my the one I
start with this morning my 34 before we
went to 40 but I also want to there's a
buff you get you can just start a new
character or just any character really
and taking King content you need to eat
level 25 so the post-match will give you
a buff that you just pop in you
automatically go to 25 and I also just
want to start from level one just to see
how you can progress through the quests
now but also the big thing is the raid
that's a huge part of the expansion and
having not touched it I nowhere near
having like a final opinion on the
expansion as a whole do we know anything
about the raids we know where it's gonna
be what it's yeah it's odds and why's
the dread-nots but it's you're fighting
not to spoil a story stuff your don't
then yeah there it's called Kings fall
and I think it's it's pretty public who
you're fighting right yeah let's just
say the story even if it was three to
four hours i think it is the build-up
lead-up to the raid yeah and and some of
the taking war stuff as well but yeah
you're pretty much gonna fight big daddy
hmm so the main thing might main
takeaway so far that's like a factual
thing that i have an opinion about is
that taken king is much better about
rewarding you for your time i think
there's a girl
and stuff but I think more than ever
there's still the element of luck
playing into it but I know what I'm
working for the most part and I know it
might be like a legendary weapon or a
legendary weapon upgrade but I know I'm
gonna at least get that in whatever form
at the end of because the quest tells
you so I feel much more in taking than
year one that my rewards were based less
on chance then yes Michael so many times
you would have finished something and
then just not even gotten anything to
get worth your time and so i guess to
that end and we're basically looking at
the first year of that destiny what do
you think of the taken king tay as
somebody who has enjoyed destiny who's
been playing dusting for the past year
is this enough of a does it feel like a
big meaty expansions to feel like it's
it's it's it was worth the wait um
definitely worth the wait I think I wish
there were more of these and less of
these smaller ones then right if
possible but I know they can't do it I
don't think because we've had these
conversations of not enough content not
enough content right that's why there's
all these small DLCs and I get it right
but like this this expansion is like a
true expansion and I wish there were
more of these and less of the like kind
of like smaller deals ease yeah because
this is actually like it feels like a
while expansion like I feel like great
I'm looking forward to it looking
forward to kind of starting fresh even
though some people are like hating
bungee because they're like oh my God
all the time I spent your one getting
all this stuff it's like well I guess
you haven't played an MMO but yeah
because that's what it is I'm Mike final
word on what do you think about
obviously we'll see review later in the
week but what are your thoughts right
now I'm cautiously optimistic so far of
the like 25 hours i played total from a
couple weeks ago and today you know i
just i need to see more but I either it
reminds me of a Reaper of souls what
that did for Diablo yes because you jump
back in and we jump back in we're
getting green items like just what
whether it's called unique we're just
regular in Diablos there's no no oh and
um very we're getting green geared
that's like a lower level gear and it
was better than the legendary gear we
had so it's just kind of like the loot
is a little more relevant and your
I feel like I'm constantly have a good
chance to get something that I'm going
to swap in obviously when you get to
higher levels that's when you start
doing this stuff that liked a loves and
I really like the late game content but
as of now the journey there is much more
interesting cool im Welling we see
review on gamespot com um we don't have
a definite date yet we're gonna the raid
release Friday so we're gonna play
through that hopefully will i'll try to
i'll be ready around them which I don't
you know it's I'll see how like it so
it's gonna be a fun weekend then yes so
this weekend early next week okay cool
awesome um thanks very much Mike my
hardy air teh coming on talking all
about destiny as is the case for the
lobby all year round we'll probably talk
again in a couple of months from the
next piece of dlc comes out or maybe
after that next patch this got a statue
if you believe the picture you know o
believers they have at least two Eric
they have if the lawsuit last week is
anything to go by at least seven more
years of soundtrack to get through so
i'm sure the that's no limit yeah
exactly yeah yeah thanks so much I let
us know and also could i have to say as
well you did a really good job
especially considering you guys have
been up for like 24 well him especially
i got you to hit my third wind you do
not look at this look at this is this is
only the my second one it's not that bad
it's not that bad you can have for
energy drinks in one day right Eric's a
consummate professional even when he's
riding on fumes so thanks our next a
giveaway of a starbucks though I've got
some major coffee bronze that we don't
say who it is oh sorry but it tastes
like [ __ ] I've had a cover it's a mocha
nasty and let us know what you think
about taking king if you played some let
us know if you're looking to get back
into destiny did you sort of get off the
boil and looking to get back into it
know that the the expansion and the hype
is back now the grinders back let us
know in the comments below
you